- Hi, everyone thank you for joining.
And we're very happy to have
Dr. Catherine Briddick from
the Refugee Study Center,
the Department of International
Development at the
University of Oxford in the UK joining us.
Thank you for joining us
virtually Dr. Briddick and we'll,
we've had more than a year long
seminar series,
and today we'll explore a
new aspect of this, which is
the intersection of gender and migration.
So we're very excited to hear you speak.
So not only will we get this in,
in live today, we're
also recording the event.
We'll put it up on our webpage, so
others will have access
to it offline as well.
So, okay.
I'll turn it over to you.
- Thank you very much for
the invitation to speak today
after what has been,
I think for many of us
kind of demanding time,
I appreciate there are
many calls on your time.
So thank you very much for
listening to me talk today
about CEDAW and discrimination experienced
in the context of migration control.
So women are disadvantaged
by migration law
in a number of different ways.
Disadvantage can be the
product of rules or practices,
which explicitly treat women
less favorably than men.
So for example, rules that
prevent women's emigration.
Usually however, gender
disadvantage flows from rules,
which appear on their face
to be gender or sex neutral,
but which actually disadvantage
women or particular groups of women.
The disadvantage can be
expressive or material,
it can entail stereotyping, the
devaluation of women's work,
loss of employment or other opportunities
and the confinement of women
to certain roles in a relationship.
It can increase women's risk
of experiencing violence,
and it can simply be violent.
Now, such rules and practices
can be characterized as being
unlawfully discriminatory
by reference to national
equality legislation
or international law.
Over the next 45 minutes,
I'm going to be presenting research,
which examines the application
of the UN Convention
on the Elimination of all
Forms of Discrimination
Against Women, CEDAW.
And I'm going to be asking
two broad questions.
Firstly, what does CEDAW's
general prohibition of
discrimination entail
in the context of migration control?
Put another way, what detailed
obligations do states assume
under CEDAW in relation to then
migration control functions?
And second, when rules and
practices are challenged
on the grounds of discrimination,
what outcome do they have
for the women who bring those challenges?
In the second part of the research,
then I'm moving to look
at the implementation
of the standards that the
CEDAW committee has set
and I that do by reviewing
individual complaints
that are brought under
CEDAW's optional protocol
over a nine year period.
As will hopefully be apparent,
the seminar therefore is rooted
in a legal disciplinary approach
to both discrimination and migration law.
And I appreciate that many of
the people joining me today
are from a multidisciplinary program.
So if you have any questions
or comments as we go,
please do ask them in
the chat and stop me,
it's much better to
clarify a term or a concept
as I unpack, hopefully what
will be my central argument.
And it should enable us to have hopefully
a more fruitful exchange of ideas
at the end of the presentation.
So I'm going to be focusing,
as I said on CEDAW,
and I'm going to be examining
the work of the treaty body,
the human rights treaty body that oversees
the conventions implementation,
the CEDAW committee.
So I'm going to do three things.
Firstly, I'm going to explain what
discrimination against women
is in international law,
secondly, I'm going to turn to
discuss what the convention requires
in the migration control context
and third I'm going to examine
the committees applications
of the obligations
it has delineated to states.
There are two parts of my argument.
The first is that I'm
going to identify doctrinal
and empirical shortcomings
in the committee's reasoning
on when and why certain widespread
migration control practices
are unlawfully discriminatory.
And second, when I turn
to looking at individual
communications brought
under the conventions
optional protocol, I'm
going to reveal a particular
kind of responsibility deficit.
A deficit between
determination and application,
between how the committee approaches
migrant women's rights in the abstract
when discharging its
general interpretive role
and when it behaves
and when confronted with a
particular rule or practice
that an individual
alleges is discriminatory.
So turning to the first of these.
As maybe apparent from the slide,
I have primary school aged children,
which means I do a lot of coloring in.
So in front of you, you
have the article one
definition of discrimination against women
that's found right at the
outset of the CEDAW convention.
And as you can see this is an asymmetrical
protection from discrimination.
So unlike CEDAW, sorry,
unlike CERD, for example,
which prohibits, which
defines and then prohibits
any forms of discrimination
on the grounds of race,
CEDAW specifically protects
women from discrimination.
And at first glance, if we
look at this definition,
CEDAW seems ideally placed
to respond to the discrimination
that migrant women may be subject to.
Article one encompasses both direct
and indirect discrimination.
It may therefore be relied
on to challenge rules,
which are explicitly
disadvantageous to women
and those which negatively affect women
or particular groups of women,
even though they appear
to be gender neutral.
The wording that I have picked
out in, I think it is yellow.
Any distinction,
exclusion, or restriction,
which has the effect or
purpose of moving into green,
establishes adverse effect,
whether or not that is intentional
as being the definitions,
crucial criteria.
The breadth of the
definition and in particular,
it's reference to language
that refers to public life.
So the prohibition of
discrimination that occurs
and economic, social, cultural, civil,
or any other field enables the convention
to non-refoulement essentially
to provide a role in the
convention that includes
gender based violence.
That is violence that is directed against
a woman because she is a woman
or which affects women disproportionately.
Now states migration control practices
such as pushbacks, for example,
may involve violence or be violence,
but there are other practices
that states engage in
such as making people
destitute for example,
or prohibited women from having recourse
to certain state services,
such as healthcare.
These services may increase
women's vulnerability
to the violence that's
perpetrated by non-state actors.
Now the CEDAW committees characterization
as gender-based violence as
a form of discrimination,
enables such rules and
practices to be challenged,
to be brought within the
purview of the convention.
Finally, article one can be relied on
to reinforce and compliment
two legal regimes, which are crucial
to international migration,
but whose key instruments fail to define
or prohibit sex or gender discrimination,
the trafficking and
international protection regimes.
The definition also requires states
to provide gender
sensitive interpretations
of those instruments.
Now, while the International Covenant
on Civil and Political Rights, the ICCPR
and the Convention on the Elimination
of all forms of Racial
Discrimination, CERD
differentiate between
citizens and non-citizens,
the CEDAW committee is
clear that the obligations
of state parties apply
without discrimination
to both citizens and
non-citizens including refugees,
asylum seekers, migrant workers,
and stateless persons
within their territory
or effective control
even if not situated within the territory.
States parties are responsible
for all their actions,
the committee appoints,
whether or not the individual
consent is in their territory.
Now the CEDAW committee,
yes.
- Catherine, sorry a question.
So who is in charge of enforcing
these articles?
- So the enforcement-
Yes.
So the CEDAW committee is the treaty body
responsible for monitoring
the application of the convention.
Now the CEDAW committee has two roles.
So one is the world I mentioned earlier,
it hears individual complaints.
So that's where individuals
can allege that for example,
they have been discriminated against
contrary to article one of the convention
and the CEDAW committee
will adjudicate on that
much like an international
court or tribunal,
although it's not that.
But the CEDAW committee will
also review reports of states.
So states party to CEDAW
have to produce information
to the committee every four or five years
to talk about how they've
implemented the convention
in their domestic law.
And there's also a role
for civil society there
and pointing out or highlighting gaps in
state's implementation of the convention.
And we might want to think about
the CEDAW committee as being a soft court.
So it's not an international
court or tribunal
like the Inter-American court, for example
but it has this monitoring
and adjudicative role.
- And how many states have signing into,
I mean, this, I mean,
complying of this convention?
- So I think there are over
a hundred states parties to CEDAW.
It's one of the most
widely ratified of the conventions.
So
it's part of the international
bill of rights, essentially.
Is part of the kind of core framework
for dealing with
international human rights law
and international rights abuses.
The reason why I'm sounding hesitant
is because while CEDAW has
a really important role
in international human rights,
so it's also the most reserved treaty.
So what that means is that states sign
and ratify the convention,
but they also enter reservations
to particular parts of it,
which means that they try and argue
that either they shouldn't be bound
by a particular provision,
such as one consent
with the quality of marriage, for example.
Or that they have a particularly
or slightly different
interpretation of it.
So it's a convention
that's ratified by states
across the world, but it's also
one of the conventions that
states try and take almost like
a pick and mix approach to,
they are highly selective
in the legal obligations they assume.
Now, the reason why I've got this quote
on the slide in front of you is because
a number of human rights
instruments in international law
differentiate between the
rights that accrue to citizens
and the rights that accrue to migrants
and CEDAW takes a different approach.
It takes a broad approach to both
its beneficiary group and jurisdiction.
So the rights that it provides
should apply to women,
whether they have a
secure migration stages
in the country that they are
in, or whether they don't,
and that's quite different
from other international instruments.
CEDAW's also establishing here in effects
based approach to jurisdiction.
So it can protect or offers protection
to individuals from harm
that crosses state borders.
So the provisional title of
my talk today was when does
migration law discriminate against women.
And I've mentioned that the
first part of the research
was focusing on working out
what state's obligations were
under international human rights law
in relation to their
migration control functions.
So article one of CEDAW defines
discrimination against women
and article two of CEDAW prohibits it.
And the committee that monitors it,
the treaty body that I must mentioned
draws on article one and two
to impugn as unlawfully discriminatory
a number of states
migration control practices.
In a moment I'm going to talk
to you about non-refoulement.
The protection that's
offered to individuals
who can't be returned to
their country of origin,
because for example, they face
serious forms of discrimination or harm,
including gender based violence.
But in an article for the American
Journal of International law,
I go into a lot more detail
about the way that, for example,
certain migration control practices,
which are widely used by
states, for example, detention
or pushback are impugned by
the committee as engaging it's
prohibition on discrimination.
A number of rules, which
are very commonly found in,
for example, British
and US immigration law
are also highlighted by the committee
as engaging in indirect discrimination.
And these are rules that for
example, mega migrants spouse
dependent on their partner or rules,
which mean that if someone wants to apply
for refugee family reunion,
they have to meet a certain
minimum income requirement.
Now, these rules on their face
may appear to be gender neutral,
but they have particular
gendered consequences.
So women might find it more
difficult than men, for example,
to meet minimum income requirements
because of gender disadvantage
in the labor market.
And similarly, women who are placed
or who are forced into relationships
of dependency with an employer or a spouse
may face an increased risk
of being subject to violence.
So the broader research
project that I'm involved in
go through states migration laws
in a much more fine-grained way
and identifies ways in which those
rules are unlawfully discriminatory.
We might though today be more interested
in how the CEDAW committee
offers protections
to refugees, and those who are in need
of international protection.
Now, the CEDAW committee has produced
a general recommendation.
On the gender-related
dimension of refugee status,
asylum nationality, and
the statelessness of women.
Now general recommendations
are an interpretive tool,
they're produced by the CEDAW committee
and they aim to unpack the core
rights that are protected
by the convention.
They tell states essentially
how they need to meet their
legal obligations and they can
be relied on by individuals
to understand when and their
rights have been violated
and what the appropriate remedies may be.
So I'm going to talk
about the way that the
CEDAW committee has done
some non-refoulement.
Now, I've already mentioned that
the CEDAW committee's definition
of discrimination against women
includes gender based violence.
And I've said, had this non-refoulement
where it was particularly important
because key instruments, in for example,
the international protection
regime don't prohibit
discrimination against women.
But there are other gaps or absences
in the international protection regime.
So you might be very well
familiar with article 1.A.(2)
definition of a refugee that can be found
in the convention relating
to the status of refugees.
And it states that
individuals are refugees
if they have a well-founded
fear of being persecuted,
because for example of their nationality
or their political opinion.
Now, whilst nationality
political opinion and race
are all protected grounds
in the refugee convention,
there isn't a ground that
relates to sex, gender,
sexual orientation, or gender identity.
And instead, individuals who seek to rely
on the refugee convention
have to bring their claim
within the final ground
that set out in the
article 1.A.(2) definition
that of particular social group.
Now I can talk for hours and
I'm not going to do so now
about the problems with the
jurisprudence on the PSG ground.
And in the Q&A we might
want to think about
particular problems in the US context
with the very restrictive interpretation
that's used by US courts and tribunals,
one, which is very much out of
step with international law.
What's really important
for us today though,
is the role that the
CEDAW committee has taken
into arguing that states need to take
a gender sensitive approach
to all of the convention
grounds, not just the PSG ground,
but for example, recognizing
women's political activism
and women's political agency
and protecting, for example,
feminist resistance to domestic violence
or feminist resistance to trafficking
as political opinions and not just
dealing with those cases
under the PSG ground.
And it's not just a
gender sensitive approach
to credibility that states
are required to take
it's about internal relocation
and all aspects of the refugee convention
definition as well.
In addition to putting forward
a gender sensitive approach
to the refugee convention,
the CEDAW committee goes
into a lot of detail
as to what refugee status determination
should look like for women.
And this is important
because this is another gap
in the article in that CSR.
So the refugee convention tells us
in article 1.A.(2) who a refugee is,
but the refugee convention doesn't tell us
how we should recognize refugees.
It doesn't tell us what
rights refugees have
when they're going through
status determination.
Do they have a right to
a lawyer for example.
And what particular rights
do vulnerable groups
going through this process require.
Now this general
recommendation makes it clear
that protection seeking women
should have their claims
determined by a system,
which is informed in every respect,
by a thorough understanding
of discrimination
and persecution on the
grounds of sex and gender
and the impacts of that treatment.
And specific examples of this gender
sensitive approach would be, for example,
requiring a woman to be
interviewed by a caseworker
who is also a woman and having
a female interpreter present.
It includes things like
providing childcare
and ensuring that victims of
torture and sexual violence
are referred to and receive
appropriate psychosocial support.
So these protections are
really important to ensure
that the gender sensitive
interpretation of the convention
is actually available to women
who go through RSD processes.
The core protection though,
general recommendation 32,
what this particular interpretation offers
is that women can use
CEDAW and rely on CEDAW
to argue that they should not be returned
to situations where
they face, for example,
discrimination on the grounds of sex
or gender based violence
and CEDAW's protection
from refoulement from this return
is broader than the protection
that applies to refugees
under the refugee convention.
So CEDAW's expansive
definition of discrimination
can be used to identify
unlawful discrimination against them
and at every stage in their journey
from countries of origin,
to countries of destination and beyond.
And CEDAW committee recommendations,
like the one that I've
just talked you through
when applied indivisibly establishes a set
of mostly reinforcing obligations,
which requires states to remedy
discriminatory treatment against women.
There are however, a number of
failures and a number of gaps
and emissions in the committees reasoning.
So when it comes to indirect
discrimination, for example,
the committee doesn't tell
women how they can evidence
differential treatment,
do they have to do so on the
basis of statistical evidence
or not, for example.
And crucially, the CEDAW committee
is silent on questions of justification.
And this is really important
from a discrimination
law perspective because
states often assert
particular rights as flowing
from their sovereignty
in the cases of migration control.
They will have kind of
very broad statements that
the progressives of migration control
requires things like detention,
deportation, pushbacks, or
variety of other practices.
Now, if these practices
have disproportionate impacts on women,
the legal question that we have to ask
is whether these disproportional
impacts can be justified
and we need the committee
to be really clear
on the circumstances in which states
are entitled to pursue those measures
and the circumstances where adverse effect
to use the language of US
discrimination law is not
justifiable treatment
and therefore the state
should change its policies.
And I think if you're
interested in kind of
following this line of argument further,
the CEDAW committee has
produced a general comment
specifically on trafficking
and global migration control.
And this has a number of
really significant gaps in it
and essentially is reads
more like a policy statement
than a legal tool that
individuals could use
if they have been trafficked, for example,
to argue for their rights against states
or for those involved in
civil society organizations,
to understand what, for example,
a process that's able to
identify victims of trafficking
should look like.
I'm now going to move
to the kind of second
parts of my research
and discuss CEDAW committee jurisprudence.
So this is about cases that
are brought to the committee.
And cases can be brought by individuals
who are in countries,
which have signed up to
CEDAW's optional protocol.
And for this research,
I reviewed nine years
worth of communications
and I identified 34 communications
as concerning states
migration control practices.
And the majority of these communications
were found to be inadmissible.
And I'll explain why some
of that was in a moment.
There were only three cases
where a breach was found.
Now, most of these cases
came from just one country
in Europe, Denmark and more
authors of communications
were represented by one man
then came from the remaining
mostly European countries.
All of these cases or the
majority of these cases
concerned non-refoulement.
So the protection of women who argued
that they should not be returned
to countries where they
faced discrimination,
persecution, and gender-based violence.
Now these findings are significant
for a number of reasons.
The first I'm going to highlight
is the fact that they do not represent
the breadth of the
committee's standard setting
in relation to migration control.
So both committees work
on direct discrimination
and indirect discrimination,
its protection of migrant
workers, for example,
and its protections for
people who are experiencing
or at risk of gender based violence,
much of that is just absent
from these communications.
And instead, what we get,
if we look at CEDAW's work
on migration control is a data set,
which is geographically skewed
to particular European countries,
and which is substantively distorted.
But there are two significant deficiencies
in the way that the
committee has approached
issues around migration control.
And the first is around
its assessment of a
communications admissibility
and the difference between admissibility
and merits determination.
And the second is that the committee adopt
such a deferential standard of review,
in some of the cases it's
called upon to decide
that effectively fails
to apply the obligations
it has delineated.
So when you bring a case
before an international court or tribunal,
you have to show that you
meet certain admissibility requirements.
You have to show that
you have, for example,
exhausted domestic remedies.
And that the thing that
you're complaining about
falls within the scope of
the relevant convention.
So when courts or human
rights treaty bodies,
like the CEDAW committee reviews
individual communications,
the assessment it goes through
is often a two-stage assessment.
First, they have to ask themselves
if a complaint is
admissible and then second
they move to considering its merits.
Has there been a violation
of the relevant right
that's protected or rights
that it's protected.
Now in the first set of
cases that I've reviewed,
the committee makes these
points and decides these points,
sequentially and appropriately.
In the second set of cases
concerning non-refoulement,
the committee collapses these
two questions into each other.
And what that does is
it leaves individuals
who are concerned about refoulement
at risk of return to
situations where they might be
experiencing persecution
or serious forms of gender-based violence.
The second problem the committee has
is around the standard of
review that it applies,
how it scrutinizes states reasoning
in asylum determination processes.
And my concern here is that the committee
adopt such a deferential
standard of review,
that it fails to protect
individuals who seek to
rely on its obligations.
So I'm going to talk about
these two deficiencies
in the analysis by drawing
on for illustrative cases.
So the first case that
I want to talk about
is RSAA versus Denmark.
So RSAA was a Palestinian refugee.
She was from Syria and she
obtained a Jordanian passport
following her marriage to a Jordanian man.
She had two children and she claimed
international protection in Denmark
on the grounds that she had
experienced domestic violence,
and that her children were
at risk of forced marriage.
Now, all of these things are protected
or should be within the purview
of the CEDAW convention.
Her claim for asylum was however refused
primarily on credibility grounds
and her and her children's
deportation was arranged.
So the CEDAW committee first looked
at the admissibility of her complaint
and under the CEDAW committees
optional protocol, article 4(2)
communication is admissible if it is
properly founded and
properly substantiated.
Now the committee reviewed her case
and found that her communication
was sufficiently substantiated.
She'd been able to show
them on a prima facie basis
that her CEDAW or protected
rights had been violated.
It then went on to consider
the substance of her
asylum claim, essentially
on a case by case basis
and applied the correct
merit standard of review,
which I've put on the
slide in front of you.
So the committee says that
it's for the authorities
of states parties to the convention
to evaluate facts and evidence
on the application of national law,
unless it can be established
that the evaluation
was biased or based on gender stereotypes
that constitute
discrimination against women
was clearly arbitrary or
amounted to a denial of justice.
So when it's looking at how
states determine asylum applications,
when, how the state
approached our essays case,
this is the standard of review
that the treaty body is applying.
So the CEDAW committee looked at the facts
in her asylum claim and
in particular they looked
at the way that she has
been deemed incredible.
They also looked at
the structural barriers
that she faced as a Jordanian individual,
but somebody who was
old Palestinian origin.
So someone who was a
refugee and had that history
in the country where that she experienced
gender based violence.
The committee held that she faced
a real personal and foreseeable risk
that as a woman who had knowingly
fled her violent husband
and had fled Jordan with
her two minor daughters
and was at risk of further
gender-based violence.
And the committee took an
intersectional approach
to the discrimination that
she had faced in Jordan.
And they found that Denmark
hadn't accorded due weight
to her status as a Palestinian refugee.
Now, earlier on, I talked about
general recommendation 32,
and I talked about the standards
that the committee has set
for how states should
determine asylum applications.
And when it was applying
the standard of review
to RSAA's case, the committee
found a number of ways
in which Denmark had not properly
applied general recommendation 32.
Essentially, Denmark had failed
to meet its obligations under CEDAW
and the return of RSS
sorry, RSAA and her children
would breach the convention.
So what we have here is
an example of somebody
who makes a claim for
international protection,
who argues that they are a
refugee under international law,
but whose claim is not recognized
by the state that she's in
and who relies therefore on
CEDAW and the CEDAW committee
to prevent her deportation,
to prevent her removal.
And because her case involves
gender based violence
and because her case
requires the monitoring body
to take an intersectional approach
to the violence and
discrimination that she fears,
she goes to the CEDAW
committee, which as, I hopefully
have explained to you in the
introduction to this talk
protects women who are refugees,
and doesn't discriminate
between the rights
that nationals and
non-nationals should have,
so should be inappropriate for,
for this kind of complaint.
And she's successful.
Denmark cannot remove her.
We don't know if she's recognized
as a refugee as a
consequence of this decision,
but we know that she's not going to face,
or we hope that she's not going to face
deportation to Jordan.
Now, I want to contrast that case
with one that was decided
just a few months later,
and it also concerned
a case against Denmark,
and it concerned a very
similar factual situation.
So this time, KIA was
someone who had been resident
in Denmark for her childhood
and she was tricked
into leaving the country
and forced into marriage.
She was subjected to domestic
and sexual violence for 11 years,
and she eventually managed to escape
and to return to Denmark,
where she made a claim
for refugee protection.
And again, her history as someone
who had Palestinian origins
and the intersectional nature
of the violence and discrimination
that she experienced in Jordan
were key parts of her claim.
But the committee didn't reach
the same decision in her case
that it reached in the
previous one, I discussed.
They found her communication inadmissible,
and what they did was
collapse the admissibility
and merits reasoning.
They applied to her and to her case,
a much higher standard of review.
Her account was unsubstantiated
because she couldn't show
that her treatment was biased
or based on gender
stereotypes or arbitrary.
So what these two cases show us
is that the committee approached
the situation confronted by two women
who both faced quite similar
and disturbing levels
of domestic and sexual violence,
but in two substantively different ways.
And in the second situation,
the committee collapses
two distinct questions,
the question of admissibility
and the question of whether
a right had been violated in such a way
as to preclude the merits
being properly considered.
And what that meant was that whilst RSS,
RSAA and her children were
protected from deportation,
KIA and her children were not.
So having exhausted the asylum
determination process in
Denmark, they risked refoulement
potentially to gender-based violence
and other forms of serious harm.
They'd gone to an international soft court
to have their rights vindicated,
and instead those rights
were not properly considered.
So that's the first failure
that I want to highlight about
the way that the CEDAW
committee approaches
some of the cases that come before it.
I want to use two more cases
now to show another failure.
And this is similar to
the first point I made,
but it is analytically distinct.
It concerns the standard of review again,
and it concerns how the
CEDAW committee approaches
migrants women's rights,
not in the abstract
when it's looking at
general recommendations,
but when confronted
with alleged violations.
So I have two cases that I
want to discuss with you,
and I want to do these
cases to chart the contours
of a particular kind of
responsibility deficit.
So the first case is from a
few years ago now, from 2013,
it concerned a woman who fled Burundi
and claimed refugee protection
on the grounds of political persecution.
She was a member of an opposition party
and had been involved
as a political activist
in a number of events and demonstrations.
Now, while she was attempting
to escape political violence,
she was raped by more than one
perpetrator at knife point.
She went through the asylum process
and her claim was rejected.
Now she then proceeds to take her case
to the CEDAW committee to
argue that she should not be
returned to Burundi.
And her case is found to be inadmissible,
but for a very striking reason.
So MEN disclosed the sexual violence
that she had been subjected,
but she didn't describe that violence
in her asylum interview
as being discrimination.
Instead, she believed
that it was coincidental
that she had been raped.
Now the CEDAW committee said that
because she phrased that part
of her client in that way,
the state party, in this case, Denmark
didn't have the opportunity
to consider her allegations
of gender based violence.
Now, this is a really astonishing decision
for the committee to reach,
because what they're saying is,
and they say it very clearly
on the face of this case,
that describing, having been raped
at knife point by three men,
but not defining that
treatment as sex discrimination
is not sufficient to raise that treatment
in your asylum claim.
Her case was inadmissible,
and we don't know whether or
not she was subject to return.
This case is interesting
because it has a really
strong dissenting opinion.
And that dissenting opinion was written
by someone called Dubravka Simonovic
who went on to become
the UN Special Rapporteur
against violence and women,
its causes and consequences.
And she rooted her dissenting opinion
in general recommendation,
19 on gender based violence,
arguing that it was a matter
of customary international law
and international criminal law,
as well as the CEDAW committee's own work
that such sexual violence was
discrimination against women
and should have been considered
properly in the case.
So MEN is one example of the committee
failing to apply its own standards
in a really clear and concrete,
and easy to identify way.
But I want to draw on a more recent case
to make this point as well.
And because I'm talking
to you from Europe,
I want to use this case to
talk about some of the issues
that are being confronted
by refugees in Europe,
at the moment, and in particular,
their return from one
European country to another.
Where they've claimed
asylum in one country,
but traveled within the European Union.
So at the moment within
the European Union,
there is a system whereby an individual
who claims asylum in one country,
but then travels on
and seeks international
or other protection in another,
if they are identified as having
done that will be returned
under European Union law.
And there are very few
exceptions to this return.
There are some that may be
based on a family reunion,
but in general, this way of
it's called responsibility sharing
but it's certainly not that,
is a way of containing
refugees in the first country
that they claim asylum and
has a disproportionate impact
on countries like Italy
for example, and Spain
who receive large numbers of individuals
seeking international protection
from across the Mediterranean.
So Abdi Osman was someone who
fled truly horrific torture
and violence in Somalia.
She was kidnapped by a
member of Al-Shabaab,
she was forced to marry the
person who kidnapped her,
her father tried to protect her,
and he was murdered in that incident.
She was subjected to
torture and sexual violence
over a number of years.
She became pregnant three times
and two of those pregnancies
were ended in a forced abortion
and the third child who was
born was taken from her.
She managed to escape
and made the incredibly
difficult, dangerous, and
illegalized journey to Italy,
where she was granted
subsidiary protection.
Now in Italy, the
treatment that she received
did not meet the standards
set out in general recommendation 32.
Ms. Abdi Osman was homeless
for a number of years,
she was detained, she
wasn't offered protections
as a survivor of sexual violence
or a survivor of torture.
And she certainly wasn't offered
any kind of psychosocial
support or assistance.
And she claimed that she should have been
recognized as a refugee,
but instead she was granted
a lesser form of protection,
complimentary protection
in the European Union.
She formed a relationship
and she wished to move
and join her husband in Switzerland,
another country in the European Union.
She did so, and she made
a claim for asylum there.
That claim was refused,
and she was returned under
the Dublin three regulation,
the system where individuals are returned
to the first country they
claimed and to Italy.
And when we talk about
returns and deportations,
and that language often
sanitize processes,
which are incredibly violent
and harmful to the individuals concerned.
And we might be familiar with
the violence of deportation
in the sense of individuals
being handcuffed
and compelled into immigration
detention or on a plane.
This was a different type of violence
because Ms. Abdi Osman
was driven to the border,
she was given a small
amount of euros in cash,
and she was left in a car park.
And she was that in that car park
with another group of refugees
and she lived on the streets
for a period of days.
She wasn't told where to go,
she wasn't told what to do,
she wasn't given any type of support
or assistance by the state.
She slowly made her way back
to her husband to Switzerland,
and she became pregnant again
and again, she faces return to Italy.
Her health, by this point had deteriorated
quite significantly.
She brings a claim to the CEDAW committee
to try and opt out of this European system
of compelling people to return
from one country to another.
And she does so on the basis that
she has been subject to
discrimination and violence,
not only in her country of
origin, but also in Italy
where she has been mistreated
now on two occasions.
The CEDAW committee have
the general recommendation
that I talk to you
through in front of them.
And Ms. Abdi Osman's legal representative
takes them through all of
the rights and protections
that I described to you.
And in particular, the support
that should be accorded
to sexual violence.
Unaccountably the
committee however, stated
it is for the sovereign
state party to determine
the nature, structure and procedures
of its own asylum system.
Moreover, they said it was
unclear that Ms. Abdi Osman
would face no specific indications
that she would not be
afforded protection in Italy.
And it reached that decision
despite the fact that as
I've explained to you,
she didn't get the
protection or health care
that she was entitled to
under the CEDAW convention
on not one but two occasions.
So she can point to two
examples in the past
where her rights have been protected
and even doing so is not sufficient
to offer her protection from return.
Her case was denied.
So this is another example
of the CEDAW committee,
just not applying, not enforcing
the standards that it is
identified as being necessary
to protect refugee women
from discrimination.
And from a legal perspective,
this is really problematic
because the committee routes the general
recommendation, 32 obligations
in that definition of
discrimination against women
that I started this seminar with.
So this isn't presented as being,
an optional set of protections
that individuals may be entitled to,
the CEDAW committee is saying that
this is required by states as
a matter of international law.
And yet when women seek to
rely on those standards,
the CEDAW committee
does not vindicate them.
And what the decision in
Ms. Abdi Osman's case does
is leave a woman who has a significant
set of health problems
as a result of torture
and sexual violence,
to be deported with a
newborn baby, to a country,
which has repeatedly failed
to meet the standards
the committee has set.
Now, these two views that I've
given you a not anomalous,
but representative of others
in which the committee's
adoption of a general recommendation
makes little discernible difference
to its adjudication of communications
that are brought to it.
So I'm sure you'll be very pleased to know
that I'm reaching the
conclusions part of this paper.
I think, and as I hoped in the first
couple of slides in this presentation
to show you that CEDAW is well-placed
to respond to discrimination
against women,
that's experienced in the
context of migration control
and there are a number
of reasons for this.
Definition of discrimination is capacious.
As I said, it covers both direct
and indirect discrimination,
including that, which is violent,
whether experienced in the
public or private domain.
The committee takes a broad effects
based approach to jurisdiction
and its beneficiaries,
which enables it in theory
to hold states responsible
for that extra territorial
and discriminatory conduct.
And in its general recommendations,
the committee has capitalized
on this advantageous positioning,
interpreting the convention robustly
and impugning as discriminatory
a range of laws and practices.
It's also, as I hope to have
highlighted required states
to make gender sensitive
determination procedures
that apply gender
sensitive interpretations
of core facets of the
international protection regime,
such as article 1.A (2)
definition of a refugee.
And more importantly, it
enables or it urges states
to increase women's
ability to migrate safely
and access protection lawfully.
There are however significant
flaws in the reasoning
that the committee has employed
in a number of instances.
And I focused in its adjudication
elements on non-refoulement.
And the protection that should be accorded
to women who claim refugee protection.
It's of concern that so few cases
are brought to the committee,
alleging discrimination
and migration control
when the committee has engaged
in such standard setting in this area.
It's of concern that a number of states
who have the laws and practices
that the committee impugns
are not being challenged
before the CEDAW committee
by individuals affected by them.
When communications are brought,
the committee's reasoning is disappointing
and frequently unprincipled.
And this is the case,
not withstanding the fact
that in some of its decisions,
the committee has given
adjudicative expression
to its commitment, to respond
to multiple and intersecting
forms of discrimination and inequality.
And I think the RSSA
case I mentioned before,
is an example of that.
It wasn't just the case
that she was a woman
who was at risk of gender discrimination,
she was also unable to access
equal protection of the law
because she was a Palestinian refugee.
So that's an intersectional
approach being taken to the
violence and the lack of
protection available to her.
However, there are a number of other cases
in the dataset that I examined,
where the committee takes an
overly deferential approach
to questions around state power
and states migration control functions.
And this deferential
approach seems to have
two elements to it, either a failure
to differentiate between
admissibility and merits
or a failure to apply its own
legal and normative standards.
And in both of these examples,
women complaining of
discriminatory treatment
are exposed to the risk of refoulement.
So there's a wealth of research
for the CEDAW committee.
So Loveday Hodson, for example, has said,
the committee has been unable to establish
much of a voice on the asylum
claims of vulnerable women.
Alternatively Bassat
Cali, Katherine Costello
and Stuart Cunningham have said the
committee has taken a tentative
and deferential approach.
I hope that you will
have seen by now that my
conclusions are much more scathing
of the committee's actions in this regard.
I think that their
reasoning is unprincipled
and as a result of that, women's rights
in the context of refugee
protection go unrealized.
The core kind of conclusion
that I am reaching in this research
is that the committee needs to
eliminate all forms of discrimination,
it has to delineate the obligations
with clarity and precision,
and then it must hold states
responsible for violating the
standards it has itself set.
So I appreciate that that was 45 minutes
that was quite dense
from a legal perspective,
and that some of you may not be lawyers
or have a background in international law,
so if you have any questions at all
about any of the material
that I've covered,
I'd be delighted to discuss
them with you further.
- I have a question, can you see me?
Here.
- Yes, please do go ahead
and I can hear you wonderfully too.
- Okay, great.
So just thinking really
practically about the US context,
is the US one of the countries
that is not a signatory of CEDAW.
And I'm also thinking about how Trump also
removed domestic violence as like
as characteristic of a particular
kind of group based discrimination.
I'm just wondering if you can speak
more to the US context here.
- Yes, so I...
There is something called the United
Nations Treaty Depository, and
I can share a link to that
in the chat in a moment,
and you can look up which states
have signed and ratified CEDAW
and I'm afraid the US is a
real outlier in this regard
in being one of the few
states that has not done that.
Now, as I understand it
under US immigration law,
individuals can seek
withholding from removal
on the basis of CAT, the
Convention Against Torture.
And so the Convention Against Torture
is very similar to CEDAW
in that it's a United
Nations legal instrument
that defines a particular
kind of wrong and then
protects individuals from
either experiencing that
in the country that they're
in or being returned to that.
So the US asylum system
does engage with a very
limited way with international law,
with the refugee convention and with CAT
but it doesn't engage with CEDAW
in the way that I've described.
Could you repeat the second
part of your question?
- Oh, I guess just the other one was that,
I guess I'm just thinking about
always the tension
between international law
and like sovereignty questions, right.
I'm thinking specifically about
the Trump administration's decision
to not count domestic violence as
like under the definition of
group-based discrimination
and how that changed,
like the ability for women
to make claims for asylum.
And then I'm thinking about like specific,
some of the rumblings in
the European Union about
not just reservations to these clauses,
but the ways in which
they're just flouting them
entirely under the name,
under the discourse of
crisis or things like that.
So I'm just wondering if
you could speak to like,
the way that maybe some of the deferential
posturing of CEDAW has to
do with playing this game
of trying to keep
countries sort of onboard
on a day to day basis.
Does that make sense?
- I'm going to try and
answer each of those in turn
and do, let me know if
I don't do so fully.
So the first one was around the specific
jurisprudence in the US around
particular social groups.
And I mentioned earlier
that the US was an outlier
in taking a very limited approach
to the definition of what
is a particular social group
and seeking through various means
to exclude women who are at
risk of domestic violence
from that definition but also
individuals who are at risk
of gang related violence as well.
The common denominators here being
that it's violence perpetrated
by a non-state actor
and there are issues around how you define
the particular social group
in the US is very restrictive
approach to that question.
But then there's a second set of questions
about how you identify whether or not
the state is willing to protect
individuals from particular
forms of violence.
And again, within the US jurisprudence,
as I understand it,
there has been attempts
to significantly increase
what an applicant has to do
to show that the state is
not able to protect them.
And the reason why I'm
hedging all my comments here
is that this is very
contested at the moment
that these cases are being
litigated backwards and forwards.
And there have been some
quite notable successes
in pushing back against
some of these approaches.
Nevertheless, I think the
core kind of consistent strand
in US jurisprudence is
a failure to recognize
that women who are fleeing
gender based violence
are refugees both on the member
of a particular social group ground,
but also really importantly,
potentially on the political
opinion ground as well.
I've come across one case at which
some wonderful students of
mine from last year shared,
which was a US case where
resistance to domestic violence,
feminist resistance to domestic violence
was interpreted as a political opinion.
And that's something that has been
litigated quite successfully
in other jurisdictions,
particularly for example,
in New Zealand and also within the EU.
Now, if the US were to
sign and ratify CEDAW,
and if it were to use CEDAWE
as an interpretive tool,
we might expect some improvements
in that jurisprudence.
But you alluded to a
separate set of problems,
which are those currently
faced within the European Union
and Council of Europe at the moment.
And these don't go just to CEDAW,
they go to something called
the Istanbul Convention,
which is the Council of Europe Convention
on Violence and
Discrimination Against Women.
And this convention is really important
because it embeds a lot
of what CEDAW has done
within the council of Europe.
But it also has specific articles in it
which protect migrant and refugee women,
including by offering
them migration statuses
and by ensuring some of the
things that I've talked about
in this talk are incorporated
into states national law,
like gender sensitive interpretations
of the refugee convention.
Now a number of states have attempted
to put reservations into those treaties
or have unsigned them.
Or states have taken quite a
negative approach to the convention.
They said a series of things about
the way that convention protects
intersectionally on the
grounds of sexual orientation,
for example, and use that as a pretext
for not offering protection from violence.
And I think this needs to
be seen within a broader
response to authoritarianism
and not just authoritarianism in Europe,
but how we think about the
role of international law in
responding or countering
some of the gendered impacts
of the rise of authoritarianism
in certain states.
And that's something
that many women who are
being activist in Poland
at the moment around
changes to the law and
abortion, for example,
are having to contest on the streets
while we talk about it in this classroom.
- Thank you.
- I have some quite a few questions.
So one is that, for example,
is there once the CEDAW has given
its determination,
is there a way to appeal
then the other one is that,
I mean, given the difference
that they have been
reaching some of the cases,
could that be explained,
for example, in the initial
representation that
these women have had in
maybe like access initially to like
a lawyer or two, or that
they are aware of how
they can bring the case.
And then the other question
that I have is that,
how is this committee
form and then for how long,
I mean, you said that some of the people
that are part of the committee
basically have some views,
or they have evolved over time as well.
- So on appeal, no,
if the committee declares
a decision inadmissible,
there's no way to appeal that.
Though you may be able to
bring a case before another
international body, another
human rights treaty body,
for example, like the
committee that oversees
the convention on the elimination
of race discrimination,
or before the CAT committee.
Now you're not allowed to
bring cases before multiple
human rights treaty bodies,
because that's precluded by
admissibility requirements,
but individuals do bring
cases often to more than one.
I think one of the things
that's interesting to look at
is why some human rights treaty bodies,
scrutinize state action, more than others.
And there is kind of an
emerging strand in the research
that indicates that the CAT
committee is much more robust
in protecting individuals
rights when they alleged
that they run the risk of being refouled.
And that in comparison,
the ICCPR, the human rights committee
and the CEDAW committee take
a much less robust approach.
And I think one of the things
you might want to think about,
although perhaps how you would design
this research is an interesting question
is why committees, which have quite
similar standards review,
why some committees are much
more deferential to states
than others are.
I think with CAT, the
Convention Against Torture's
definition of torture is very narrow
in comparison with, for example,
CEDAW's definition of
gender-based violence
and so it may be that its
precision and its focus,
and that narrowness
enables the CAT committee
to take a much more
robust approach to states.
Whereas because CEDAW
potentially offers much
broader panoply of rights,
it's therefore less
assertive and enforcing them.
I mean, we would have to think about
whether that was the correct
and principled legal approach,
but that may be one reason why
the CEDAW committee is more differential.
The other thing I wrote
down was membership.
So yes, members serve for
particular periods of time,
they are nominated, I cannot remember
off the top of my head how long.
I'm going to say five years,
but we can check. (laughs)
The relevant documents.
So it will be set out in the convention
and for how many years.
Individuals are nominated
by states to serve
but when you are there,
you serve in your individual
capacity as an expert.
So you should not put
forward, for example,
your state's views on
any particular problem,
you sit as an independent individual
who's hopefully either legally
informed or legally rooted,
or has that background
that would enable you to
interpret the convention correctly.
And sorry, I missed the
third part of your question.
- No.
So I was thinking if,
yeah.
How they're treating the cases
would differ either because
their own background or
that they're representing
or because it happens to have
a composition that basically
is more harsh than others
in certain cases.
- So I think that's a really
interesting hypothesis,
but I don't think that...
I suspect that that's not the reason
simply because all human
rights treaty bodies
have very similar
processes by which experts
are nominated by states and
then serve on committees.
- And the fact that, I mean,
how do the women access,
I mean, help in order to bring
their cases to the CEDAW,
is that-
- All right, legal aid?
Yes, you mentioned that.
So again, that will depend on each state's
national provisions.
So within the European
Union, a number of states
and to the UK,
obviously you need to remember
the European Union now,
do have provisions that enable individuals
to receive legal advice and representation
that's free of charge.
And even when that's not available,
there are a number of
not-for-profit organizations
who also provide that assistance.
Interestingly, a number
of the cases I reviewed
are individuals who bring those cases
representing themselves.
And so the quality of legal
advice I think, is a real issue.
I think you're absolutely
right in pointing to that
as being one of the
reasons why of these cases
are not successful when they
should be on their face.
- Okay.
And then I imagine that once
you start the process, then,
I mean, like the case that
you shown that because
it has not been set in a
specific way so therefore
it has to set the
consequences as well so...
- So,
now that may be a problem within
some courts and tribunals,
but it shouldn't be before
a human rights treaty bodies
who don't see individuals.
So you don't litigate directly.
You don't argue in Geneva
or in New York, for example,
you don't stand at the lectern and explain
how your rights have been violated.
A lot of these cases are just decided
on the basis of materials,
which are submitted to the committee,
which the committee then reviews.
And because the committees
procedures around evidence
and how it makes decisions
are fairly flexible,
I think you are going to be
kind of less disadvantaged
as an individual representing yourself
before human rights
treaty bodies, potentially
than before, for example,
the Inter-American court
or the European court of human rights.
It's interesting as well,
that in a number of
the cases from Denmark,
legal representation was
highlighted as being a problem.
And I think the committee
is rightly concerned
that cases are just being
brought to the CEDAW committee
where the individual consent
is not receiving the
quality of legal advice
and representation that they should.
And I think I'll leave there.
(indistinct)
(laughs)
- [Trinh] This is a really
specific question, Catherine,
why do you pick nine-year
for your data sets?
- Do you know that that's simply
the case that I was looking
for a range of communications
that would be both before
and after the adoption of the particular
general recommendations
that I was interested in.
So in the last decade, we
have general recommendations
adopted on trafficking, on
asylum and refugee status
and gender-based violence.
And so I wanted a number of communications
to come from before and after the dates
that those recommendations
were adopted to see
what the adoption of a recommendation,
what difference that
made to particular cases.
And so nine years just
enabled me to do that
and enabled me to read the
kind of requisite volume of
communications, to be
able to reach decisions.
You could go back
further, fairly obviously.
And all of the conclusions that
I have started to set out to
are premised on the fact that
that's a limited dataset,
nine years worth of cases.
- Going back, sorry, to some of the point
that I mentioned, I
mean, do you know there,
how many times the
committees change as well?
I mean, there are like...
If they were to be like five years,
so sort of see two or three sort of set
of committee just,
I mean, just to test the hypothesis that
some composition might be
sort of harsher to other ones
of the committee.
- So I think that that information
must be publicly available,
how long people served, when people joined
and when people left.
I think the two cases that I showed
that concerned individuals
who were Palestinian refugees,
who claimed asylum in Denmark,
which were decided so close to each other
indicates that it's not the composition
of the committee that's
necessarily the problem.
And because one would imagine that it was
not necessarily entirely
the same group of people
sitting on the committee,
but that there would be
quite a significant overlap
between the individual sitting.
- [Teresa] Yeah.
- That's certainly an avenue
that I could and should pursue.
So thank you for suggesting it.
- Any more questions
in the room or on the
in Zoom?
No.
- I have a question if that's okay.
(laughs)
Because I'm aware that I'm predominantly
potentially speaking to an audience
who are based in the US or
potentially who are US citizens
and are familiar with US
immigration and nationality law.
I will be interested in to what extent
you find arguments based
on international law,
interesting or compelling or relevant
to your research and interests.
Because if you're within Europe
kind of geographically
rather than politically,
these are arguments that
you're very familiar with
and that you would engage in
potentially even before
domestic tribunals,
but I'm aware that that's not the case
potentially for a number
of you who may be involved
in activism or litigation or research
where international law
potentially seems quite removed or
not relevant to the types of arguments
that you're interested in making.
- I could...
I'm not a legal scholar, but
I'm a migration and border
enforcement scholar.
And I think I can speak
first just as a US citizen
to the way in which I think
international laws still
like broadly read as like an
overstepping of sovereignty.
I think that actually probably is the
sort of sentiment on the street
and I think that that's
growing in Europe too, right.
But I'm also...
But my research takes
place in North Africa
and in West Africa.
Where international law is often viewed as
sort of just an extension
of a colonial imposition
and particularly around
issues of gender, right?
Like you have such a different,
such different interpretations
of what constitutes violence
sort of,
all those, like all that bundle of issues
around gender and then also,
if we're thinking about
international courts,
we're thinking about
who gets prosecuted in those courts.
They're mostly like post-colonial leaders.
And so there is a lot of resistance.
I think there's both at the state level,
a diplomatic and geopolitical
motivation to participate
in these conventions,
but there's also like a deep seated
suspicion and resistance against them
to the end that some of
the African countries
have formed their own court, right.
Like, so, yeah, so it's
complicated, I think.
(chuckles)
- I mean, one of the cases
I excluded from the sample
was a woman who got recognized
as a refugee in the UK,
but then brought a case against Libya
for the gender-based violence
that she had experienced
there as a feminist activist.
So I would say that it's
not entirely the case
that international law is kind of viewed
with suspicion in those instances,
because this was an example of somebody
who, when they got to a
jurisdiction of safety,
one of the first things they
did was bring a case against
the country that they had fled from
to argue that their international
legally protected rights had been violated
and interestingly, that case
was entirely successful.
And so that kind of
speaks to your research,
but I think it also reflects
on some of the things
that I've been talking about,
which is when somebody is
recognized as a refugee
and they're bringing
a case about the state
that they have fled from,
the CEDAW committee can recognize that
and find the violations.
But when individuals are bringing cases
against refugee receiving states
for violations of their rights,
the CEDAW committee is less able
to recognize that and to
vindicate those rights
in the migration control context.
- Yeah, the other thing is that, yeah.
I guess,
I mean, when you ask the
question to the people attending
this seminar,
probably your,
I mean, it's not representative of what
the majority of the US
people are thinking about
because yeah as you said, in
other countries, you think,
I mean, international law sort of
protecting you or some of the
last resort of some of the
protection of rights
then you start more like
an invasion of their own sovereign.
- And it matches my intuition
as a model that I think
a lot of people that are sort of
already have an anti-immigrant
anti-refugee disposition
also have a deep skepticism of
international law writ large
and so I think sort of,
it seems to me that like in at least
the US political context that
I don't think international
migration law is like
seen as a lever likely to
change a lot of things, I guess.
- Well, if I could follow up
too, on the Libya example,
I think like from the
north African context,
the fact that that women's
case was adjudicated against
Libya and not against,
the European Union or Italy
for initiating the pushbacks,
like pushbacks or army,
Libyan defense or
militias, or all of that,
like creating those particular contexts,
I think sort of under,
like underscores the point
that people feel like a suspicion, right.
Of international law as still really
serving European interests
or Euro American interests
over global interests or being
selective about those maybe-
- And I think, yeah.
I would agree with the broad
thrust of that analysis.
And I think that the case I
talked about towards the end,
Ms. Abdi Osman's case is
a perfect example of that
because a European system,
which was predicated in deterrence,
which was predicated
in containing refugees
in particular areas in
Europe, which as I said,
I kind of went through
the facts of that case
in a lot of detail, 'cause I
wanted to really make the point
that on two occasions,
all of these rights protected
by CEDAW had been violated
and yet the committee
says we have no evidence
that if she's going to be returned,
she would face those violations.
What do they need then actually
under those circumstances,
what possibly could she
have presented to them?
And so we might see that
case as an example of
migration control imperatives
within the European Union
and this particular EU model
of returning individuals
to the first country where
they've claimed asylum
being vindicated by the
committee in this respect,
because there's no
challenge available to her.
She can't, or, it's very difficult
for her to do so through
European Union mechanisms
and the one mechanism we might
think should be available
to her as someone who's
experienced sexual violence,
torture and gender based violence, CEDAW
the committee doesn't take the role
that has been given to
it in international law
and I think that's really troubling.
When I discuss this research,
I'm normally discussing it in countries
where individuals have the opportunity
to use the mechanisms
that I'm talking about.
And so it's very different
when I speak to you
because it's much more
abstract potentially
depending on where you might go and work
after your studies here.
And so that often kind
of presents a particular
kind of conflict for me because
a lot of the time I will point to
particular things and
states and say, look,
this, the CEDAW committee has
impugned as discriminatory.
So when I talk to legal
activists, I'll say,
why don't you bring a case?
You use really clear
recommendations on this point
and you have, for example,
a group of individuals
who require protection,
so you should consider
this international remedy.
So on the one hand, sometimes
when I'm talking to audiences,
I say, use the remedy,
but it has this problem.
Whereas when I'm talking to you,
I can't even say use the remedy,
I'm painting a picture of an
international regime that has
potentially only
tangential interest to you
or tangential impact on the
work that you may be doing.
- There is a question
on the chat about how,
if the gender and COVID-19 guidance
from international bodies has resulted
in any shift in policies, because
the problems on the ground
on gender are very real.
- Ask about how guys
are initiating policies.
Yes.
I
don't know a CEDAW rooted
answer to that question,
other than that
the convention protects equal access
to health care and maternity
services, for example,
and there has been
successful litigation where
women's rights, for example,
to healthcare around having
healthy children was denied,
particularly on intersexual
grounds, such as
race and being a member
of an indigenous group.
There's kind of some really
interesting jurisprudence
of the CEDAW committee on that
doesn't relate to COVID-19 though.
The only specific guidance
I can think of would be from
UNHCR, which has like a data portal
where it's produced kind of an analysis of
either restricted or
non-restricted measures
adopted by states in relation to COVID-19
because we're aware that the
pandemic is used by states
as an opportunity to kind of entrench
or further entrench
policies of immobility.
I agree that that presents a
series of issues around gender,
and particularly in relation
to gender based violence
but I can't think of a kind
of clear document or source
that I can point you to.
I've got Sarah's question now and there
it's characteristically challenging.
So thank you for that.
So have there been any
interaction between the
committees reasoning,
the European Court of Human
Rights and other treaty bodies?
And there has been.
So the European Court of Human Rights
regularly refers to the
work of the CEDAW committee
in its cases on violence and
discrimination against women.
And there are kind of certain key cases
such as Opus versus Turkey, for example,
where the court differs
to the CEDAW committee's
definition of violence and
discrimination against women
and says that CEDAW is the
specialist legal regime
that regional courts should turn to
when adjudicating on, for example,
article 14 non-discrimination cases
involving gender based violence.
Has there been any interaction
here when we think about
challenges to Dublin returns
because you're right,
Abdi Osman is very similar
to a number of cases
where individuals have gone
to the European Court of Human Rights
to challenge their removal
from one EU country to another
and what they've normally done
is relied on article three,
which is the prohibition of torture,
inhuman and degrading treatment.
And we might want to think
about why Ms. Abdi Osman
brought a case to the CEDAW committee
and not to the European
Court of Human Rights
and I don't know the answer to that.
I think that it's
interesting to think about
if you have more than
one international court
or tribunal to go to why you
would choose a UN treaty body
and not a regional court.
It may well be that the court's
reasoning is so restrictive
when it comes to things
like Dublin returns
that she thought that the CEDAW committee,
because her case was so,
involved gender based
violence in every point of
her journey and was so kind of,
it's almost hard to approach it without
that kind of non-discrimination
gender-based violence lens
that she thought the CEDAW
committee would vindicate
her rights more than the
European court would do.
But you're absolutely right
to point to those cases
at the European Court of Justice
and at the European Court of Human Rights.
And obviously MSS is one
and Terra Cal is another,
where you see the two courts engaged in a
kind of transnational conversation about
the circumstances in which individuals
can be returned to either Italy or Greece
and the treatment that
they would face there.
The committee does not draw
on any of that discussion.
It does recount kind of
paragraph after paragraph
of kind of NGO evidence about
the treatment of asylum seekers in Italy,
but then it doesn't again,
link that to its general recommendation
on the treatment of asylum
seekers and refugees.
So again, there's this, this mismatch.
And I would agree entirely
that returns to Italy
violations are only very rarely found
in comparison with returns to Greece.
Although the standard of treatment
was quite similar in the two cases.
- Okay, so thank you
very much, Dr. Briddick.
So if you join me as well, and
so hopefully at another
time we might be able
to have you here around and
this is our last seminar for the fall,
and we'll see you back
in the spring next year.
Thank you very much then.